- We're here with Julie
Andrews and her daughter,
Emma Walton Hamilton.
Give it up!
(audience applauds)
So, Julie and Emma have obviously
known each other forever.
They also work on many,
many projects together.
When these two were on over the summer,
we tested how well they know
one another with a little game.
Well, now it's time to
up the stakes, people,
and see if they're able to
finish each other's sentences.
This is, that's what she said, she said
♪ That's what she said she said ♪
That's what she said she said, oh my gosh.
These songs, I love them.
Okay. Here's how it works.
I'll read the beginning of a sentence
for either Julie or Emma,
one at a time, of course.
They both have to finish
the quote by writing
what would have been said.
If they can give the same answer
or something close, they'll get a point.
If they get three right,
everyone in the house seats is getting
a $100 gift card to CASETiFY.
So, just saying. No pressure, ladies.
CASETiFY makes beautiful,
drop-proof phone cases,
and accessories designed by style leaders
and customized by your right on the site.
So are you ready, ladies?
Don't let the audience
down is all I'm saying.
- Oh, that's naughty.
- No pressure.
All right, well, this first -
- Pen in hand.
- Pen in hand, I like it.
That competitive nature, I'm into it.
This first one is for Julie.
Julie was asked to sing her
favorite song from her movies.
She said, I'll sing blank.
- I have to write down
my answer, or Emma does?
- We both do.
- Both, you both.
And we're going to see if
you can, if you both know.
- Okay.
- Okay, so Emma, what did
you say your mom would say?
- I said, she wouldn't be able to choose.
- [Kelly] Oh, she wouldn't
be able to choose.
- Can you see that?
- Yes.
Cause she's a Libra,
and there's no way she
could pick just one.
- That's awesome.
Also true for Geminis.
Okay. Well, Julie, what did you say?
- Honest to God.
- What is it?
Oh, impossible to choose!
Oh my God. That's amazing.
All right, that's a point.
Nicely done, ladies.
Okay, wait. Next, Emma.
When asked about her childhood hobbies.
Emma said there's one that's unique.
It's blank.
Write your answers.
Childhood hobbies.
There's one that's unique.
I'm so intrigued.
- Okay.
- Okay, Julie, what did you say Emma said?
- There we go.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Wait a second.
- [Kelly] Unicycle riding.
You ride a unicycle?
You've ridden a unicycle?
Oh my, is that what you said?
What did you say?
Riding a unicycle.
Wait, wait, this is
very unique and random.
Where the heck did that come from?
- I rode it on one of
mom's TV shows once, so,
on her variety special.
I made a little tour around
a giant jar of peanut
butter once on my unicycle.
- I was actually talking
about "My Favorite Things,"
and out you came on your unicycle
in front of my favorite, peanut butter.
- Oh my God.
I love that story.
I love that.
Who has ridden a unicycle?
No one I know. Now I do, Emma.
All right, well, next up,
Julie forgot her anniversary
one year.
It's okay, she said. I will blank.
Write your answers.
I'm actually guilty of
forgetting things like that.
I love that I'm having earl grey tea
with Julie Andrews on my show.
I feel very sophisticated.
- You and me.
- Oh God, I love it.
All right, Emma, what
did you say she'd say?
- Well, this is tricky, Kelly, because,
Mom would actually never
forget an anniversary,
or anyone's birthday
or any important date.
I can't seem to center
this right. Here we go.
- Oh my gosh. Are you serious?
I feel like such a
horrible human right now.
What?
- No, she's pretty obsessive
about remembering everybody's birthdays
and everybody's special events.
- Well, I do lapse occasionally.
I have to say I'm only
practically perfect.
- Practically perfect.
(audience applauds)
- Well, wait, Julie, what did you say?
- Well, Emma, you won this one, too.
Hold on.
I don't think I ever
could is what I'm saying.
- Oh my gosh. Are you serious?
I, okay, here's the thing, Julie.
I feel like such a, I
mean, collectively, my,
we've forgotten anniversaries.
I mean, there's a lot of
birthdays that go around, guys.
Like, I'm just saying, like,
I know I'm a horrible
human in this moment,
So cheers to you, Mrs. Andrews.
- I can talk about a lot
of birthdays going around,
because I beat you hands down, Kelly, so -
- [Kelly] Oh my God -
- But, probably you
should remember them now.
- Now, you win, not only the game,
but being a better human than me.
So, congratulations.
So, you guys really do know
what she said she said.
What a great game title.
That means everyone in our house seats
is getting $100 CASETiFY gift card.
CASETiFY makes beautiful
drop-proof phone cases
and accessories designed by style leaders
and customized by you right on their site.
That's not all, though.
You're also getting a copy of
Julie's new book, "Home Work,"
available on Google Play.
Thank you so much, ladies.
I love you, Julie and Emma,
and I love seeing y'all again.
Great to see y'all.
The new book is called "Home Work,"
a memoir of my Hollywood years,
and the podcast is "Julie's Library."
Be sure to check both of them out.